vers 4h30 nos satellites ont
détecté une tempête s'approchant du
site de la mission Ares 3 sur Mars lors de l'
évacuation l'astronaute Mark Watney et a
tué c'est Mark Watney et je suis toujours en vie
je n'ai aucun moyen de contacter la NASA ou mes
coéquipiers c'est le définitif
histoire de survie, c'est presque comme une
version de science-fiction de Robinson Crusoé face à
des chances écrasantes, il ne me reste qu'une
seule option Je vais devoir faire de la science à
fond
Houston soyez prévenu que maman est toujours en vie
Je suis dedans  film sur un gars coincé sur
Mars tout seul mais il y a tout cet
autre aspect de ce qui se passe sur la
planète Terre si mes calculs sont bons il
va mourir de faim bien avant que nous
puissions l'aider il a un astronaute qui est
bloqué sur Mars
il en a cinq  en rentrant à la maison risquez-vous d'en
perdre six ou en sauvez-vous cinq c'est
plus grand qu'une personne Non donc tout ce
drame c'est entre Jessica
Chastain et toute l'équipe qui a
quitté
Mars  à savoir si nous devrions ou non
changer de cap pour sauver Watney
c'est quelque chose que la NASA a exprimé qu'ils ont
rejeté nous le faisons ensemble ou pas du
tout
il est impossible qu'il soit encore en vie
vous